avait beaucoup mieux on va vous faire
une interview tchèque a pu
quel est l'homme politique qui vous
donne des boutons normale à l'homme de
ne leur accorde pas assez d'importance
qu'est ce qui vous fait vomir dans le
cinéma américain
aujourd'hui tout ce qui se montre les
strip-teases comprendre quel est le
comique américain aujourd'hui qui vous
donne de la fièvre liasse de xynthia au
sujet de quelques milk américain
voudriez vous être amnésique non pas les
noms want you make me la dernière fois
que votre coeur s'est arrêté de battre
c'était pour qui pour sa femme et sa
fille dans son élan seule la dernière
fois que j'ai vu des larmes dans les
yeux de simone il aurait payé trop trop
tôt ça vous fait mal quand vous voyez
des jeunes qui connaissent pas vos fils
non pas du tout et quand on vous prend
pour l'animateur du téléthon ça vous
fait de la peine ouais pourquoi tu payes
tu ailles a besoin d'être à l'automne
j'ai fait le téléthon
anna vreizh one belgium nine hundred
million d'ha long et j'ai j'ai ramassé à
bignon 900 millions de dollars
oui
donc ils peuvent dire ce qu'ils veulent
moi j'ai fait ce que j'avais à faire
ça vous fait mal quand vous réalisez que
beaucoup de vos amis sont morts non
dragon eye avec qwest qu'une fois ue ok
ok à need to know j'ai besoin de savoir
instant au stop de chant à apprendre que
dans le show au you try to get me to be
nasty est-ce que tu essaies de me vendre
mauvais nom john light by sonia backes
beach et c'était vrai je sois candidat
et je peux pas faire ça latroy hawkins
orban j'aime ça que tu me répondras les
mêmes ishare j'aime je peux je prends
soin débuts du web des geeks and the
make the world war je fais tout ce que
je peux croire y aubry
goodman je suis un nom très beau
les sens
m
or